the NFL been in the news a lot they've
had a lot of problems recently well just
yesterday Dallas Cowboys running back
Joseph Randle was arrested for
shoplifting
yes arrested for shoplifting that
happened yesterday today the NFL had
this to say about it
Dallas Cowboys running back Joseph
Randle was arrested for shoplifting on
behalf of the NFL would like to say we
couldn't be prouder Randle is a student
of the NFL's victimless crimes program a
course that transitions players from
committing violent crimes to nonviolent
offenses
I thought NFL players can only commit
assault with a deadly weapon but thanks
to victimless crimes last week I got
arrested for public urination but we
don't stop there gifted lawbreakers are
matched with mentors to find
white-collar crime opportunities that
will pay the bills now move the funds
over perfect that's it my big hands and
fast reflexes used telling me strangle
people now I'm running my own Ponzi
scheme the NFL is proud of its
commitment to turn dangerous criminals
into highly productive ones because the
only place for senseless violence is on
the field
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you